my name is julie grenka i am a
population geneticist at ancestrydna
which is a personal genomics company i
did my
undergraduate degree in biometric and
statistics at cornell university so sort
of a combination of biology and
statistics and then after my
undergraduate i came to stanford
university where i did my phd in biology
i think when i i first got interested in
genetics was in was in middle school we
were doing punnett squares and learning
how inheritance occurred and i just
really found it super interesting and
sort of how it explains basically
everything so as a population geneticist
of ancestry dna i do a variety of stuff
trying to a variety of research trying
to sort of hone in on the methods behind
how we estimate ancestry and how we
estimate relatedness between individuals
and i think now
even now just from going from genotype
data to sequence data to sort of see the
vast amount of information that we're
now getting from genetics now that now
the i guess the the problem is just to
figure out how we can analyze all that
and how that we can make sense of all of
it so i think to really see the scale of
it increase over time has been really
fascinating you know there's a lot of
places where genetics might come in not
just in humans but in other organisms so
sort of thinking about and observing
basically the way that genetics is
kind of underlying everything that
happens around you so i think kind of
observing and seeing what questions
drive you can also be important in
addition to those sort of necessary
foundational skills like programming and
statistics